Loony, you want to say hi? Now, if I wanted to say hi, I would need to knock on something. There we go! See, I know how to make this dog work. You want him to bark, you just knock on something. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 84 recorded on June 24, 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview special guest Tony Van Eerd. So I've got the same thing. My mom's side is like Irishottish and a few other things
Loony，你想打个招呼吗？现在，如果我想打招呼，我需要敲点什么。这就对了！你看，我知道怎么让这只狗工作。你想让他叫，你只要敲点什么就行。欢迎来到 ADSP，这是 2022 年 6 月 24 日录制的第 84 期播客。我是 Connor，今天我的联席主持是 Bryce，我们采访了特别嘉宾 Tony Van Eerd。我也有类似的情况。我妈妈那边有点苏格兰爱尔兰血统和其他一些血统
like some spanish or whatever you know that kind of mix and my dad's side is dutch straight up straight up dutch as far back as you go yeah i was looking it up because i was wondering what the van means and i guess it means like from yeah it's like he's from Erd. I'm just going to call you that for now. No, no, no, no. I was traveling, right? As we do. And went through the customs at Toronto Airport or whatever. Went through something.
比如西班牙血统什么的，你知道那种混血。我爸爸那边则是纯正的荷兰血统，纯正的荷兰血统，能追溯到多远就有多远。是的，我查过这个，因为我想知道 Van 是什么意思，我猜它的意思是“来自”。是的，就像他是来自 Erd。我暂时就这么叫你吧。不，不，不，不。我当时在旅行，对吧？就像我们经常做的那样。然后通过了多伦多机场的海关什么的。通过了某个地方。
And the guy looks at my passport and all this stuff. He says, oh, of the earth. Worldly. He's like, worldly. Of the earth. I'm like, what are you talking about? He's like, your last name. Van Eerd. Of the earth. And I'm like what are you talking about he's like your last name van eard of the earth and i'm like oh right it's of van is of yeah okay so he's just tony of the earth yeah and he's like he's like it means worldly i'm like it probably means farmer
然后那家伙看着我的护照和所有这些东西。他说，哦，大地的。很世俗。他就像是，很世俗。大地的。我说，你在说什么？他说，你的姓。Van Eerd。大地的。然后我说，你在说什么？他说，你的姓 Van Eerd，大地的。然后我说，哦，对了，Van 是“……的”，是的，好吧，所以他只是大地的托尼。是的，然后他说，他就像是，这意味着世俗。我说，这大概是农夫的意思
you know like it doesn't mean worldly no no it just look it just means that your family were actually yeah intergalactic explorers. You were the Tony from Earth. We're the subset of the family from Earth. But then you go through all that and you get to the gate. And then you meet up with all your other buddies you're traveling with, right? And the other guy I'm traveling with, he goes like, hey, my last name means blah, blah, blah. I'm like, did you go through the same guy?
你知道的，这并不意味着世俗。不，不，这只是说明你的家族其实是……是的，星际探险家。你就是来自地球的托尼。我们是家族中来自地球的那一小部分。但随后你经历了这一切，来到了登机口。然后你遇到了和你一起旅行的其他朋友，对吧？跟我一起旅行的另一个人说，嘿，我的姓氏意思是巴拉巴拉巴拉。我说，你是不是也经过同一个人？
And I guess we figured like a bunch did you go through the same guy and i guess we we figured like a bunch of us went through the same person and he just tells everyone what their last name means and it doesn't matter what language you are and stuff and you can imagine someone who works at the airport like that and goes through staring at passports all day needs a hobby and his hobby was like knowing languages found a way to keep it interesting. Do you know what your first name means, Tony? I'm named after a mafia guy. Really? Tony.
我想我们大概发现……你是不是也经过同一个人？我想我们大概发现我们当中有一群人都经过了同一个人，他只是把每个人的姓氏是什么意思告诉了每一个人，不管你是什么语言之类的。你可以想象一个在机场工作、整天盯着护照的人需要一个爱好，而他的爱好就是了解各种语言，并以此来保持有趣。你知道你的名字是什么意思吗，托尼？我是以一个黑帮分子的名字命名的。真的吗？托尼。
Yeah. I'm like named after an Italian mafia friend of the family. Oh, I thought you meant like a fictional character. No. No, you mean. Yeah. Yep. Born in Windsor,
对。我好像是以一个意裔美国家庭黑帮朋友的名字命名的。哦，我以为你是指虚构的角色。不。不，你是说。是的。没错。出生在温莎，
you know, there's some mafia in Windsor. That's the Canadian mafia? Yeah. I mean, there's mafia everywhere, so yeah. It's like they extort you, but they're really nice about it.
你知道的，温莎有些黑帮。那是加拿大黑帮？对。我的意思是，到处都有黑帮，所以是的。就好像他们勒索你，但他们的态度真的很好。
They say sorry when they're robbing. Sorry about that. Well, or maybe they're the French Canadian mafia because I'm about to offend some some number of my friends some of my audiences but all those all those stereotypes about canadians being nice that's not the french canadians it all depends whether we're holding a hockey stick or not holding a hockey stick that's and i mean that in the best i mean that in the best possible way also uh ol Olivier one day mentioned that we take all our anger and through some secret ritual, we take all the anger out of us and put it into Canadian geese.
他们在抢劫时会说抱歉。真是不好意思。好吧，或者他们可能是法裔加拿大黑帮，因为我即将冒犯我的某些朋友、我的一些观众，但关于加拿大人很好的所有那些刻板印象，法裔加拿大人可不是这样的。这完全取决于我们手里拿着曲棍球棍还是没拿着曲棍球棍，这就是……我是以最好的方式，我是以最可能好的方式这样说的。还有，嗯，Olivier 有一天提到，我们把所有的愤怒，通过某种秘密仪式，把我们身上所有的愤怒都抽离出来，放进加拿大雁体内。
And that's why they are the way they are. And then we send them south. It's a long-term plan. Well, we have a lot of topics probably to talk about tonight. We're all going to be in... T-minus from when we're recording, T-minus 24 days, we're all going to be in Toronto,
这就是它们为什么会变成那样。然后我们把它们往南送。这是一个长期计划。好吧，今晚我们大概有很多话题要聊。我们都会在……从我们录制的时候算起，倒计时 24 天，我们都会在多伦多，
CPP North. I think technically when this gets released, it'll be 24 minus 7 is 17 17 days um it depends actually when are you getting into because the conference is monday to wednesday which starts on the 18th i believe i get in on the 17th um i'm flying from japan because i'm going this next saturday i go to london for cpp on c and then i go to from l CPP on C. And then I go from London to Tokyo for this quantum computing conference, which is like a whole podcast episode we should do about that. And then I go from the quantum computing conference in Tokyo to Toronto.
CPP 北区。我想严格来说，当这期节目发布时，应该是 24 减 7 等于 17，17 天。嗯，这实际上取决于你什么时候到，因为会议是从周一到周三，也就是 18 号开始，我相信我会在 17 号到达。嗯，我从日本飞过去，因为我这个星期六要去伦敦参加 CppCon，然后我从 L……CppCon。然后我从伦敦飞到东京参加这个量子计算会议，这就像我们可以为此做一个完整的播客节目。然后我从东京的量子计算会议飞往多伦多。
Technically I stop in New York for like three hours, but to Toronto. And that'll be my July, basically. I'll be on the road for three weeks. So you land on Sunday. Tony, when do you... And Tony, tell... Actually, we have any... We do a terrible job of introducing our...
严格来说我在纽约停留了大约三个小时，但目的地是多伦多。基本上这就是我的七月了。我要在路上待三个星期。所以你星期天落地。托尼，你什么时候……而且托尼，告诉……事实上，我们有任何……我们在介绍我们的……方面做得太糟糕了
We just start chatting. Yeah, we do. I'm sure there's a number of folks. We always mention... We were chatting on Discord yesterday, and Tony mentioned that he's probably either the number one or at least top two tied with Sean mentioned individual. individual said his name already.
我们直接开始闲聊了。是的，我们确实是。我确信有很多朋友。我们总是提到……我们昨天在 Discord 上聊天，托尼提到他可能是第一名，或者至少和肖恩提到的个人并列前二。个人已经说过他的名字了。
How am I going to stay ahead? I was like going to go through this whole thing. Tony, Tony, Tony. Yeah. I was going to go through this whole, this whole episode.
我怎么保持领先？我本来打算经历这一切。托尼，托尼，托尼。是的。我本来打算经历这整个，这整个插曲。
I only go by episodes, not how many times you say my name, but you just, how many episodes I get brought up. And I think I'm on, I think I'm on the top of your list. Maybe we should add a tag because the website, we tag topics. And whenever we say your name, you know, Tony tag.
我只按集数算，不按你说了多少次我的名字算，而是按我被提及的集数算。我想我排在你们名单的最前面。也许我们应该加一个标签，因为网站上我们会给主题打标签。每当我们说你的名字时，你知道的，托尼标签。
Not as a guest, just as mentioned. No, we need a Tony counter. We need one of our audience members to go and count all the number of times that we've mentioned Tony. I think that audience member is me. I'm that pathetic that I keep track. If we had transcripts, it'd be a lot easier. It's probably a one-line or two-line Perl script to get that. But anyways, Tony, tell the people about yourself,
不是作为嘉宾，只是作为被提及者。不，我们需要一个托尼计数器。我们需要我们的一个听众去数一数我们提到托尼的次数。我想那个听众就是我。我很可悲地一直在做记录。如果我们有文字稿，那就容易多了。写一个一两行的 Perl 脚本就能搞定。不管怎样，托尼，跟大伙介绍一下你自己，
where you're from, what you do, your history. You used to work at a famous company, and now a famous company too. Yeah, I wonder. He's worked at two or three famous companies. I was going to say, yeah. I just mean as far as Canadian companies go go it's pretty famous right that's what you're talking about no not that one okay which famous company are you talking about connor he's talking about blackberry i think that's what i'm talking about but i thought he meant adobe
你来自哪里，你是做什么的，你的履历。你曾在一家著名的公司工作，现在也在一家著名的公司工作。是的，我在想。他在两三家著名公司工作过。我本来想说，是的。我只是说就加拿大公司而言，它挺有名的，对吧？这就是你在说的？不，不是那家。好吧，你在说哪家著名的公司，Connor？他在说黑莓，我想这就是我在说的。但我以为他说的是 Adobe
the other famous company but that's not that's not canadian company i said famous canadian company yeah but who cares about Canadian company? I mean, Canadians do. Yeah. Um, no, you're outnumbered,
另一家著名的公司，但那不是加拿大公司。我说的是著名的加拿大公司。是的，但谁在乎是不是加拿大公司？我的意思是，加拿大人在乎。是的。嗯，不，你寡不敌众，
right? Grace, like this whole thing, even though, even though Connor is fine for me to be outnumbered because you're Canadian. Bagels are coming up at some point, but first let's let Tony introduce himself. Oh,
对吧？Bryce，就像这整件事一样，尽管，尽管 Connor 觉得我寡不敌众没问题，因为你是加拿大人。百吉饼在某个时候会出现，但首先让我们让托尼自我介绍一下。哦，
at the same time, I've been waiting. Does that look like a blackberry flavor you got there? The best one? Of course it is. What were we just going to talk about? Is that the Canadian about? I don't know. People sometimes say
与此同时，我一直在等待。你手里那个看起来像黑莓口味吗？最好的那种？当然是。我们刚才要聊什么来着？那是加拿大人关于什么的？我不知道。人们有时说
I say the Canadian about. You don't really do the Canadian about, Connor. Sometimes I do. you would be connor you could definitely pass for an american you have almost no discernible accent have you how do you put up with those kind of insults i mean tony has like a tony has like a slightly more of an accent than you and it and when it comes out more like a little bit more but But you have an almost imperceptible accent. It's funny that Bryce says that because sometimes when I'm abroad, people actually think I'm from New York. And they're like, oh, you have a New York accent.
我说加拿大的“about”。你其实不说加拿大的“about”，Connor。有时我会。你绝对可以冒充美国人，Connor，你几乎没有明显的口音。你当年是怎么忍受那种侮辱的？我的意思是，托尼的口音比你稍微明显一点点，当它出来的时候……更像是一点点，但是你的口音几乎察觉不到。Bryce 这么说很有趣，因为有时我在国外时，人们实际上以为我来自纽约。他们会说，哦，你有纽约口音。
I was like, I don't know what that is, but I'm not. And I'm not really certain why you have that accent, Connor. I did act in a play when I was younger called Lost in Yonkers. And you just never dropped it again. I wasn't planning on doing an accent, but apparently I'm really a method actor. I do consider myself the Christian Bale of the C++
我说，我不知道那是什么，但我不是。而且我真的不确定为什么你有那种口音，Connor。我年轻时确实演过一部戏剧，叫《尤克斯的迷失》（Lost in Yonkers）。然后你就再也没改掉这个口音。我本没打算带口音的，但显然我真的是个方法派演员。我确实认为自己是 C++ 社区的克里斯蒂安·贝尔
community. I don't even know what to do with that. You were talking about me. Come on. We'll be quiet for you. So it starts with, yeah, I will be flying into Toronto down the 401 from KW area on Sunday. So, yes, I'm in Canada. I'm in, well, I live in Guelph, if anyone knows where that is, and work in Waterloo.
我都不知道该怎么接这话了。你刚才在谈论我。得了吧。我们会为你保持安静的。所以它是从……是的，我将于周日沿着 401 公路从 KW 地区飞往多伦多。所以，是的，我在加拿大。我在……好吧，如果有人知道那在哪的话，我住在圭尔夫（Guelph），在滑铁卢（Waterloo）工作。
I work at Christie, who makes projectors, which I will say- Christie doesn't make projectors. He makes amazingly mind-blowingly cool projectors. Did you go to, you went with Hannah to the planetarium? I go to that planetarium all the time because my grandfather volunteered at the natural history museum for like 20 years and his buddies with neil degrasse tyson but yeah i did not know it was christian projectors i'm not surprised yeah so those are the best projectors in the world like there's no no doubt those are they're like
我在科视（Christie）工作，他们生产投影仪，我要说的是……科视不生产投影仪。他们生产令人惊叹的、脑洞大开的酷炫投影仪。你去过吗？你和汉娜一起去过天文馆吗？我经常去那个天文馆，因为我外祖父在自然历史博物馆做过大约 20 年的志愿者，他和尼尔·德格朗塞·泰森（Neil deGrasse Tyson）是好朋友。但是，是的，我不知道那是科视的投影仪，我一点也不觉得意外。是的，所以那是世界上最好的投影仪，毫无疑问，它们就像是
i think i think we can only say a million to one contrast ratio. Only. Only a million to one, but it's actually higher than that. This is the Hayden Planetarium at the American Natural History Museum in New York, the best museum in the world. People had trouble measuring the contrast ratio because it's so high. We project, because it uses DMDs, the little chips that are mirrors. And normally you project light on the mirrors and then you project it out the projector. And we said, no, no, no. We're going to project light onto the mirror and then that goes to another mirror and then that goes out the projector.
我想，我想我们只能说拥有一百万比一的对比度。仅仅。仅仅是一百万比一，但实际上比那还要高。这是纽约美国自然历史博物馆的海顿天文馆，世界上最好的博物馆。人们很难测量对比度，因为它太高了。我们投影……因为使用的是 DMD，也就是那些由微型镜子组成的芯片。通常情况下，你把光投射到镜子上，然后通过投影仪投射出去。而我们说，不，不，不。我们要把光投射到镜子上，然后光会传到另一面镜子上，再通过投影仪投射出去。
So the projector costs twice as much as it should cost because we doubled everything internally. But it gets rid of secondary light that you would get. So there's no, like there's this problem of black level light that you can get in the projector and it just disappears. How many projectors is it? Because it's planetarium, so it protects the 180. Yeah, I don't know for sure,
所以投影仪的成本应该是它正常成本的两倍，因为我们在内部把所有东西都翻倍了。但这消除了你可能会遇到的二次光。因此，投影仪中可能存在的黑电平光问题完全消失了。这是多少台投影仪？因为它是天文馆，所以它要投影 180 度。是的，我不确定，
but it's like six, I think, or something like that. Six or eight or something. And the people there, the people at Hayden are very picky. One of our most picky uh customers ever like they they did not settle for anything less right we basically made a projector we designed a projector for them right wow is there like a youtube video that uh won't capture i'm sure uh the contrast yeah if i google this will i be able to find some i don't know i don't know if i'm telling you stuff I'm not supposed to tell you,
但大概是六台吧，或者诸如此类的。六台或八台左右。那里的员工，海顿的员工非常挑剔。是我们最挑剔的客户之一……他们绝不将就，对吧？我们基本上是为他们制造了一台投影仪，为他们设计了一台投影仪，对吧？哇，有没有一段 YouTube 视频能拍到……我确信对比度……如果我谷歌一下，能找到一些吗？我不知道，我不知道我是否在说不该说的话，
but, you know, anyone could figure it out by, like, the projector's there or someone could take it. Were you there for, have you ever been there? I haven't been there. I didn't get to go to that. I get to go to places. It's really weird when you work for Christie because if you do go on site, you go somewhere and you work on site at, like, midnight to 6 a.m.
但是，你知道，任何人都可以通过……比如投影仪就在那里，或者有人可以拍下来。你在那儿吗？你曾经去过那儿吗？我没去过。我没能去那儿。我确实有机会去一些地方。在科视工作是一件很奇怪的事，如果你去现场，你得去某个地方，并在晚上 12 点到早上 6 点之间在现场工作，
because you have to go there when it's closed. So I've been to all these big places only when it's closed, but I haven't been to Hayden. And to avoid getting into Tony into trouble, I'll just say big places such as, you know, theme parks, things like that.
因为你必须在它关门的时候去。所以我去过所有这些大地方，但都只在它们关门的时候去过，不过我没去过海顿。为了避免给托尼带来麻烦，我只说一些大地方，比如主题公园之类的。
You know, I like to say, you may have gone to his children. I like to say universal studios because that's one of the ones that I can say and other large theme parks and places yeah um anyhow before christy i worked at this other place called blackberry let me just take another drink of this blackberry liquid oh it's so i didn't even i'm not sure if that was intentional but wow so my my favorite part of i knew tony part of the time when he was at blackberry
你知道，我喜欢说，你可能去过他的孩子们。我喜欢说环球影城，因为那是我能说出的地方之一，还有其他大型主题公园和地方。是的，无论如何，在科视之前，我在另一个叫黑莓的地方工作过。让我再喝一口这个黑莓液体，哦，真是的……我甚至不知道这是否是故意的，但哇……所以，我最喜欢的……我认识托尼的时候，他正是在黑莓工作的那段时间，
sort of towards the end and my favorite part of tony at blackberry was the period towards your end of the end of your time at blackberry where it seemed like your job function was just to file patents yeah i went through a stage if i if I recall, the benefit system for, like, the reward system that they gave you for filing was like. Well, there's two parts. There's two parts. I mean, the reward system is not much different than anywhere else, I don't think. But they did have a thing where anybody who was a director or something had people under them, had a quota. They just said, well, you know, you've got, not that I did.
差不多是在尾声的时候。我最喜欢他在黑莓的那段时光，也就是你快要离开的那段时间，当时看起来你的工作职责就是申请专利。是的，我经历过一个阶段，如果我没记错的话，他们的福利系统，比如他们给你申请专利的奖励系统就像是……好吧，有两部分。有两部分。我的意思是，奖励制度和其他地方没有太大区别，我并不这么认为。但他们确实有一项规定，任何担任总监或类似职位、手下有人管理的人，都有一个配额。他们只是说，好吧，你知道的，你手下有……并不是说我有。
I don't like having people under me. But my manager or something had like 50 people or 100 people under him. So they said, we would expect, you know, this many patents every year or every quarter. I expect 10 patents out of 100 people or some number. And my manager was telling me this one day and I said, all right'll we'll do that this afternoon for you he's like what i said i'll just sit down with a couple other guys and we'll just we'll just make up patents for you this afternoon and then we did every whenever we needed more patents we're just like i can think of whatever some of them are dumb some of them are actually good i got patents on predicting the future i got the awesomeness patents How many patents do you have?
我不喜欢手下管人。但我的经理手下大概有 50 人或 100 人。所以他们说，我们期望每年或每个季度能有这么多的专利。我期望 100 个人能产出 10 宗专利，或者某个数字。有一天我的经理跟我说了这个，我说，好的，今天下午我们就为你搞定这个。他问什么？我说，我会和另外几个家伙坐下来，今天下午就为你炮制出一些专利。然后我们就这么做了。每当我们需要更多专利时，我们就会想出一些……有些很蠢，有些其实还不错。我获得了关于预测未来的专利，我获得了牛逼专利。你有多少专利？
I might have like 10 or something Not that many I used to work with a guy Gary Klassen I worked with him at Christie And at Blackberry He's the guy who wrote BBM The good old Blackberry Messenger
我大概有 10 个左右吧。没那么多。我以前和一个人共事过，叫加里·克拉森（Gary Klassen），我在科视和他一起工作过，在黑莓也和他一起工作过。他就是编写 BBM 的那个人，美好的老黑莓信使（BlackBerry Messenger）。
He's got like 200 patents And he didn't even know it The lawyer one day told him That he's like 200 patents he's just like and he didn't even know it the lawyer one day told him like that he's on 200 patents he's like why but it's because like every blackberry every bbm patent had had his name on it kind of thing yeah um he's a great guy by the way um i also seem to recall you towards the end of your time at blackberry describing like your your station and situation at BlackBerry as like you knew where the escape hatch was if you needed to exit the building at BlackBerry.
他大概有 200 项专利，他自己甚至都不知道。有一天律师告诉他，他有 200 项专利，他就觉得……他自己甚至都不知道，律师有一天告诉他，他名下有 200 项专利，他问为什么？但这是因为，每个黑莓、每个 BBM 专利上都有他的名字，诸如此类。是的。他是个很棒的人，顺便说一句。嗯，我还隐约记得在你快要离开黑莓的那段日子里，你形容你在黑莓的岗位和处境是，如果你需要离开黑莓大楼，你知道逃生舱口在哪里。
It's kind of sad that I... Should I be even saying these things? But I went to my manager and said, like a round of layoffs were coming. I knew they were coming. And I said, put me on the list. I said, I'm fine. I can get they you know there's other people on my team they can all get other jobs but i'm like i feel the most confident of everyone here that i'll land on my feet so i said put me on the list and he's like i can't do that and he said he said i asked my
真有点可悲，我……我甚至应该说这些事情吗？但我去找我的经理说，有一轮裁员要来了。我知道它们要来了。我说，把我加到名单上。我说，我很好。我可以……你知道的，我团队里还有其他人，他们都能找到其他工作，但我说，我比这里任何人都更有信心，我能安然度过难关。所以我说，把我加到名单上。他说，我不能这么做。他说，我要求经理把我加到名单上——就像我的经理要向上级汇报那样——把我加到名单上，你知道的。
manager to put myself on the list like my manager was going up on their chains put me on the list you know yeah it's kind of bad when when once you start seeing rounds of rounds of layoffs um but blackberry still exists right they are still out there and it's in your car blackberry is in your car right yeah qnx yeah yeah that's what we uh you know nvidia does a lot of car stuff and uh and q and x it's it's real big 225 million cars yeah um but anyhow but let's but we should talk about the good times blackberry because you used to be very excited about should we just give like a little little couple minute um description because i'm i'm sure there's at least one or two people that are below the age
是的，这有点糟糕，当你开始看到一轮又一轮的裁员时。但黑莓仍然存在，对吧？它们依然存在，而且就在你的车里，黑莓就在你的车里，对吧？是的，QNX，是的，是的，这就是我们……你知道，英伟达做了很多汽车相关的东西，还有 QNX，它非常庞大，有 2.25 亿辆汽车。是的。但无论如何，但我们应该聊聊黑莓的好时光，因为你过去对……我们是不是应该简单花个几分钟时间做个描述？因为我确信至少有一两个年龄在……我不知道，25 岁或 20 岁以下的人，实际上根本不知道黑莓是什么，
of like i don't know 25 or 20 that actually don't know what blackberry is um have no idea what bbm is um uh where where do we start um blackberry was was one of the first i mean there was even before black there there was like palm and stuff blackberry was really on the on the bleeding edge of of phones before the iphone right um blackberry was the first thing to really have a really good email and stuff in your pocket and and corporate the corporate world lived and died off blackberries uh all all business was done on a blackberry because you could quickly connect and do your email and get everything. And,
完全不知道 BBM 是什么。嗯……我们从哪里开始呢？黑莓是第一批……我的意思是，甚至在黑莓之前，还有 Palm 之类的前期产品，但黑莓真的是在 iPhone 出现之前走在手机最前沿的……黑莓是第一款真正把非常棒的电子邮件等功能装进口袋里的产品，企业界靠黑莓维系，所有的商务都是在黑莓上完成的，因为你可以快速连接、处理邮件并获取所有信息。而且，
and just, it was the businessman's, you know, pocket device. And it was the, it was the number one phone before the iPhone came out. And then the iPhone came out and I didn't work at BlackBerry when the iPhone came out.
而且，它就是商人的口袋设备。在 iPhone 问世之前，它是当之无愧的头号手机。然后 iPhone 问世了，而 iPhone 问世时我并没有在黑莓工作。
I worked at Adobe and I saw it and I was like, man, my friends at BlackBerry, I got to tell them that they're in trouble. And no one at BlackBerry believed that the iPhone was going to cause a problem. I was like, man, my friends at BlackBerry, I got to tell them that they're in trouble. And no one at BlackBerry believed that the iPhone was going to cause a problem. They're like, it doesn't even have copy and paste. It's, you know, that iPhone sucks.
我在 Adobe 工作，我看到了它，然后我想，天哪，我在黑莓的朋友们，我得告诉他们他们有麻烦了。黑莓没有人相信 iPhone 会带来问题。我当时想，天哪，我在黑莓的朋友们，我得告诉他们他们有麻烦了。黑莓没有人相信 iPhone 会带来问题。他们觉得，它甚至连复制粘贴都没有。你知道的，那部手机太烂了。
It's like, guys. I just read a Twitter thread about the iPhone not having copy and paste. And like, apparently they just didn't have time to get around to implementing it. But yeah, like I was reading the said, and I like, I didn't even know that the first iPhone didn't have copy and paste. But it was from one of the original like iPhone devs. And he was like, yeah, you know, we just really, we just ran out of time. We just didn't have time for copy and paste. The original, a friend of mine jumped on the iPhone early, right? The iPhone also didn't have apps.
就像是，伙计们。我刚在 Twitter 上看到一个关于 iPhone 没有复制粘贴功能的帖子。显然他们当时只是没时间去实现它。但是，是的，我当时在看，而且我甚至不知道第一代 iPhone 没有复制粘贴功能。但这是其中一位原版 iPhone 开发者说的，他说，是的，你知道，我们真的是，我们只是时间不够了。我们只是没有时间做复制粘贴。原版……我的一个朋友很早就入手了 iPhone，对吧？iPhone 也没有应用程序。
Like you couldn't write an iPhone app. And the first iPhone app was the camera, or not the camera, the light. And it wasn't even the camera light. It wasn't the flash. It was, it turned your screen white. And that was a 99 cent app. And my friend at the time said we should start writing iphone apps i was like the first app was 99 cents it made the screen white and i was like yeah yeah that'd be
就像你没法为 iPhone 写 App 一样。而第一个 iPhone 应用是相机……或者说不是相机，是手电筒。甚至都不是相机的闪光灯。它只是让你的屏幕变白。那是一个 99 美分的 App。我当时的一个朋友说，我们应该开始开发 iPhone 应用。我当时想，第一个应用售价 99 美分，它让屏幕变白了，然后我就想，是的，是的，那会
kind of cool but you know i don't got time for that man being like early days you could have made a killing right yeah when a white screen made money anyhow um i worked at Blackberry. Before Blackberry, I worked at Adobe for almost 10 years. Mostly worked on Adobe Premiere. Also worked on some internal, what we called internal open source, which is like shared code within Adobe. So my code is in all the products. I can always point to an Adobe product and say I got some code in there. Before Adobe, I worked at a place called Inscriber.
挺酷的，但我可没时间搞那个，伙计。在早期，你本可以大赚一笔的，对吧？是的，一个白屏就能赚钱。不管怎样，我在黑莓工作。在黑莓之前，我在 Adobe 工作了将近 10 年。主要从事 Adobe Premiere 的工作。还做了一些内部工作，我们称之为内部开源，也就是 Adobe 内部共享的代码。所以我的代码存在于所有的产品中。我总是可以指出某个 Adobe 产品并说里面有我的代码。在 Adobe 之前，我曾在一家名为 Inscriber 的公司工作过。
And Inscriber's got like a huge amount of strangely large number of people from this tiny company work in interesting places now because it was just this like little hotbed of smart people. And you should explain what Inscriber does because that's actually one of my favorite of the Tony jobs. Is this like the general magic of Canada or something? Sounds kind of like it.
Inscriber 有着数量惊人的、奇怪的大量来自这家小公司的员工现在都在有趣的地方工作，因为它只是一个充满聪明人的小温床。你应该解释一下 Inscriber 是做什么的，因为那实际上是我最喜欢的托尼的工作之一。这难道是加拿大的某种“通用魔法”吗？听起来有点像。
Inscriber, well, for you, Connor, and our Canadian listeners, CP24, you know, that TV station? All that text and everything that's going on, that's Inscriber. So Inscriber is known for doing text for television. We do graphics for Wii. I worked at Inscriber when it was like,
Inscriber，好吧，对你来说，Connor，还有我们的加拿大听众，CP24，你知道那个电视台吗？所有那些文字和正在发生的一切，都是 Inscriber 的产品。所以 Inscriber 以制作电视文字而闻名。我们为 Wii 制作图形。我在 Inscriber 工作时，
I started there when there was like 10 people. I was there for 10 years. I still consider, I say Wii. I still say Wii even though I haven't worked there for 20 years. It's one of the first places I worked. It was known for texts for television. And it just was better looking text than everyone else was doing. And also...
我刚进去的时候大概只有 10 个人。我在那里待了 10 年。我仍然认为……我还是说 Wii。我甚至在离开 20 年后依然说 Wii。这是我工作过的第一批公司之一。它以电视文字而闻名。它制作的文字比其他人做的都要好看。而且……
And you should explain what time period this was in. Yeah. Because some of our younger audience members... Didn't live. Weren't alive. When did I... About 1990 or so is when I started there. And at the time, if you wanted to put text on TV,
你应该解释一下这是什么时期。是的。因为我们的一些年轻观众……没有经历过。还没出生。我是什么时候……大约 1990 年左右是我开始在那儿工作的时候。在当时，如果你想在电视上打字，
like in the TV studio, like you're in the newsroom and you want to put up so-and-so reporting from Baghdad, that was a $100,000 machine. And it was, you know, a box that only did text for television. And if you wanted to change the font size or something, you know, you had to get down, you know, download. You had to, like, from the company get new fonts at different point size. Like, it was, nothing was dynamic, right? So, my boss, a guy named Dan Mance, really great guy, he wrote a thing called Inscriber.
就像在电视台里，比如你在新闻编辑室，想打出“某某人在巴格达报道”，那需要一台价值 10 万美元的机器。而且它是一个只能做电视文字的盒子。如果你想改变字体大小什么的，你知道，你得去……下载。你必须从公司获得不同字号的新字体。这就像，没有什么东西是动态的，对吧？所以，我的老板，一个叫 Dan Mance 的家伙，人非常好，他写了一个名为 Inscriber 的东西。
Basically wrote it on his own under DOS. This was a DOS program that would do text and would put it out on a Targa card before NVIDIA or people like that really existed. And you could buy a computer and this card and this software and $10,000, you would have a better text output on top of, you know,
基本上是在 DOS 下靠他自己一个人写出来的。这是一个 DOS 程序，可以处理文字，并将其输出到 Targa 卡上，那时 NVIDIA 或类似的公司根本还没真正出现。你可以买一台电脑、这张卡和这个软件，花 1 万美元，就能在视频上方输出更好的文字，
overlaid onto video. Um, and it costs 10,000 bucks and you could change the font size on the fly and change the colors and do all this stuff. And people are like, Oh my God, that's so much better. Um,
叠加到视频上。嗯，它售价 1 万美元，你可以随时更改字体大小、更改颜色并做所有这些事情。人们就觉得，哦天哪，这好太多了。
so inscriber did that as their, as their main thing. Um, they, the reason I ended up at Adobe is because inscriber and Adobe made a deal together to do like a joint venture because, uh, thing um they the reason i ended up at adobe is because inscriber and adobe made a deal together to do like a joint venture because adobe premiere had a really bad text engine even though adobe as a company had a good text engine premiere had a bad video text engine so they instead of using
所以 Inscriber 把这个作为他们的主要业务。我最终来到 Adobe 的原因是因为 Inscriber 和 Adobe 达成了一项协议，做了一个类似合资企业的事情，因为……嗯……我最终来到 Adobe 的原因是因为 Inscriber 和 Adobe 达成了一项协议，做了一个类似合资企业的事情，因为 Adobe Premiere 的文字引擎真的很烂，尽管 Adobe 作为一家公司拥有很好的文字引擎，但 Premiere 的视频文字引擎很烂。所以他们没有使用
their own they bought inscribers um and i i got bought i got bought bought by Adobe. Which is actually funny because I worked, I was at, after about five years at Adobe, someone from HR came to me and said, oh, you actually have been at Adobe for 15 years because you're technically a merger, right? You were a merger from Inscriber to Adobe. So your five years is actually 15 years. And we owe you like this much vacation time.
自己的引擎，而是买下了 Inscriber 的。然后我被……我被 Adobe 收购了。这其实挺搞笑的，因为在大约在 Adobe 工作了五年后，人力资源部的一个人来找我说，哦，你其实已经在 Adobe 工作了 15 年了，因为你技术上是通过并购过来的，对吧？你是从 Inscriber 被并入 Adobe 的。所以你的五年实际上是 15 年。我们欠你这么多假期。
And like, you know, we owe you a sabbatical. And we owe you all this stuff because we screwed it all up. And I'm like, all right, I'm taking Fridays off the rest of my life. Like I had so much vacation time, I would never catch up on my vacation time. And I'm just bad at using vacation time. So they probably still owe me vacation time and i'm just bad at using vacation time so they probably still owe me vacation time 10 years later uh anyhow i've been doing pixel plus plus my whole life that's that's that's the summary of that because i was at an inscriber doing pixel processing
而且，你知道的，我们欠你一个长假。我们欠你所有这些东西，因为我们把这一切都搞砸了。我说，好吧，余生里我周五都不上班了。我积攒了那么多的休假时间，以至于我永远也休不完。而且我本就不擅长休假。所以他们可能还欠我假期，10 年后我依然不擅长休假。不管怎样，我一辈子都在搞像素处理，这就是对这一切的总结，因为我在 Inscriber 做像素处理，
i was at blackberry making making the scrolling and everything smooth it was a thing called liquid graphics to make the blackberry 60 frames per second and a sad story there was that the people that were we were in the team that was doing the graphics you know library that you would call we were doing the c++ graphics library that you would call you would call it from your java application right and then it would call down into our c++ eventually and we're like this there's no way we can do 60 frames per second because the chip that they were buying for the next the next piece of hardware and and they're like you know it's got to be 60 and we're like do the math it literally you can't push that many pixels across the bus like there's just just it's not hard to figure out the bus bandwidth is this the screen size is this you can't get this many pixels at 60 frames per second and they're
我在黑莓负责让滚动和所有东西都变得顺滑。有一个叫 Liquid Graphics（流体图形）的东西，可以让黑莓达到每秒 60 帧。一个悲伤的故事是，我们这群人……我们属于负责图形的团队，你知道，你们会调用的那个库。我们在编写你们会调用的 C++ 图形库，你们从 Java 应用程序中调用它，然后它最终会向下调用到我们的 C++。我们当时就想，这根本没法做到每秒 60 帧，因为他们为下一个硬件采购的芯片……他们说，你知道的，必须达到 60 帧。而我们说，算算账吧，你字面意义上就无法通过总线推送那么多像素，这根本不难算出，总线带宽是这么多，屏幕尺寸是这么多，你根本不可能在每秒 60 帧下传输这么多像素。他们却说，
like huh the only thing that got me was like we're the software guys you are the hardware guys you should have already figured this out so we had to convince them to like switch what chip they're going to buy because of course they wanted to buy the cheaper one like it's just not going to work anyhow here we are now so did you end up going back to so it was inscriber adobe blackberry and then back to adobe and then christy no christy or blackberry to christy so the iphone came out before you joined blackberry yes i i went to blackberry with a with an iphone in my pocket and whenever anyone um started talking about how should this work how should i'm just like let me just pull out this phone in my pocket how about you make swiping work like this it was like they had really weird ideas on how things should work and then and then the worst the worst part
哈？唯一让我不解的是，我们是软件人员，你们是硬件人员，你们本该早就算出来的。所以我们不得不说服他们更换要购买的芯片，因为他们当然想买便宜的那款。总之这根本行不通，而我们现在就在这里。所以你最后是回到了……所以是 Inscriber、Adobe、黑莓，然后又回到了 Adobe，然后是科视？不，是科视……或者从黑莓到科视。所以 iPhone 在你加入黑莓之前就发布了？是的，我口袋揣着 iPhone 加入了黑莓。每当有人开始谈论这个应该怎么运作、那个应该怎么运作时，我就会说，让我掏出口袋里的手机。你们怎么不把滑动操作做成这样呢？他们对事情应该如何运作有着非常奇怪的想法。然后……然后最糟糕的部分，
too is that they didn't they got in this state of being worried about, like, there was features of the BlackBerry that worked better than, well, even just a simple thing I noticed recently. If you plug in a phone, if your phone dies, battery dies, right? You get home, you plug it in. Your phone doesn't turn back on. It just charges. But then you still have to press the button to, like, boot it back up, right? A BlackBerry phone, if it dies, you plug it in, it just turns itself back on it just charges but then you still have to press the button to like boot it back up right a blackberry phone if it dies you plug it in it just turns itself back on because of course like you're going to want to turn it back on why why do why do i have to tell it that right and there was an argument about that at blackberry about like the next phone is not going to turn
也是最糟糕的是，他们陷入了一种状态，开始担心黑莓的某些功能其实比……甚至只是我最近注意到的一件简单的事情。如果你插上手机，如果你的手机没电了，电池没电了，对吧？你回到家，把它插上。你的手机不会自动开机。它只是在充电。但你仍然必须按下按钮才能重新启动它，对吧？黑莓手机如果没电了，你把它插上，它就会自动开机。它只是在充电，但你仍然必须按下按钮才能重新启动它，对吧？黑莓手机如果没电了，你把它插上，它就会自动开机，因为当然啦，你肯定想把它重新开机。为什么，为什么我必须告诉它这件事？黑莓内部曾为此争论过，认为下一款手机不会自动开机。就像，为什么不呢？他们说，嗯，iPhone 就没有那样。我说，好吧，也许这是一个他们还没搞懂的好功能。就像 iPhone 当初也没有复制粘贴一样，你知道，你时不时就会听到这种言论：“哦，我们不应该那样做。”这个屏幕键盘，它应该一直显示大写字母，还是同时显示大小写？
itself on it's like why not they're like well iphone doesn't do that it's like well maybe it's a good feature that they haven't got to like iphone didn't do cut and paste either you know like and you just get that every now and then of like oh we shouldn't do that the um this on-screen keyboard should it show um uppercase all the time or uppercase and lowercase um ip used to, I don't know what it does now, but it used to always show only uppercase letters on the keyboard, right? Even if you're in lowercase,
以前，我不知道现在怎么样了，但它过去总是只在键盘上显示大写字母，对吧？即使你处于小写状态，
it would only show uppercase because the keyboard was like, as if it was a physical keyboard that doesn't change, right? And then Android, it shows uppercase and lowercase. It's a better, it's more feedback on the UI. And BlackBerry had uppercase, lowercase, and then they switched it to uppercase only.
它也只显示大写字母，因为键盘就像是一个不会改变的物理键盘，对吧？而 Android 则会同时显示大写和小写。这是一个更好的功能，能提供更多 UI 反馈。而黑莓曾有过大小写，后来他们把它改成了只显示大写。
And I'm like, that's stupid. That's bad UI. They're like, well, that's what iPhone does. Okay, well, can't win any arguments if you just, you know, why just be a duplicate when there's good features that you had that you, I don't know. So we have to talk about the most iconic
我说，这太蠢了。这是糟糕的 UI。他们说，嗯，iPhone 就是这么做的。好吧，如果你只是……为什么要当一个复刻版呢，明明你们以前有那么好的功能，我不知道。所以我们必须谈谈最具标志性的
feature, part of the black barrier keyboard which of course is the keyboard yeah i was hoping you were going to say the the different lights in the top left hand corner for the types of mess that that is something that even to the flashing i know so many people will say that's what they miss the most is the flashing light. Yeah. So why, so why, why did the physical keyboard die? You know what? I think, well, there's two reasons,
黑莓键盘的一部分，当然就是物理键盘。是的，我本来希望你说的是左上角用于不同类型消息的不同指示灯。那绝对是……甚至连闪烁的灯光……我知道有很多人说那是他们最怀念的东西。是的。那么，为什么……为什么物理键盘会消亡？你知道吗？我觉得，嗯，有两个原因，
right? Cause, cause it uses up too much screen real estate, right? People just want the bigger screen. And a lot of people, so there's a gap, right?
对吧？因为，因为它占用了太多屏幕空间，对吧？人们只想要更大的屏幕。而且很多人，所以这里有个代沟，对吧？
When, when the iPhone came out and integrated, like basically the, the demo about it, I went to, you know, I was working for Adobe. I went down to San Jose to visit the team because I was working for Adobe. I was still up in Canada, right? We had a small office up here. I ran an office for Adobe. This is why I'm not a manager. It's not a good idea to have me run an office.
当 iPhone 问世并整合了……基本上是关于它的那个演示，我去……我在 Adobe 工作。我去了圣何塞拜访团队，因为当时我在 Adobe 工作。我还在加拿大的办事处，对吧？我们在上面有一个小办公室。我曾为 Adobe 经营过一个办公室。这就是为什么我不是个管理者。让我去经营一个办公室可不是什么好主意。
But we went down and the iPhone had just come out. And of course, everyone in Silicon Valley just bought one the next day, right? So everyone on the Adobe team that I was working with had one. And they just said, look at this. And then they went to Maps. They found a nearby restaurant. They pressed the button. They called the phone. They they made a reservation we went to the restaurant right which is something we all just do now that was a killer demo and they didn't even mean it to be a killer demo they just did it yeah and you couldn't do that on any other phone because it just wasn't all there just wasn't all put together right um and the iphone had that and so now everyone switches the iphone because it's just got killer features and then they well wait did the first iphone have maps yeah i think was it google maps yeah it was
但我们去了那里，iPhone 刚问世。当然，硅谷的每个人第二天就买了一个，对吧？所以和我一起工作的 Adobe 团队里的每个人都有一个。他们只是说，看看这个。然后他们打开地图。他们找到了附近的一家餐馆。他们按下按钮。他们打了电话。他们预订了座位，我们去了餐馆，对吧？这是我们现在所有人都会做的事。那是一个杀手级的演示，而且他们甚至不是故意要把它做成杀手级的演示，他们只是那么做了，对吧？而你在任何其他手机上都做不到这一点，因为当时一切都还没有整合在一起，对吧？
google maps right from the start it was just everything was smooth and integrated right um and then people loved the keyboard because you actually can type faster and everything's faster but then you get you learn to live without it because of all these other features that are killer features, and then you don't feel the need to go back to the keyboard. But I still miss it. I know I'm better with the physical keyboard. It's just nicer.
iPhone 做到了这一点，所以现在每个人都转向了 iPhone，因为它有着杀手级的特性。然后他们……等一下，第一代 iPhone 有地图吗？对，我想是谷歌地图吧？是的，从一开始就是谷歌地图，一切都那么流畅和整合，对吧？然后人们喜欢键盘，因为你确实可以打字更快，一切都更快。但随后你学会了没有键盘也能生活，因为所有这些其他功能都是杀手级功能，然后你就不觉得有必要回到键盘上去了。但我还是很怀念它。我知道我用物理键盘打字更好。它就是更好用。
Also, the BlackBerry had a... I don't know, but because with the physical keyboard, you can't do all the sorts of tricks that they do with the virtual keyboard. Like with the virtual keyboard, they can do all this, you know, Oh, you pressed here, but you really meant to press here. Oh yeah. You know, cause, cause, cause where you think you press with your finger versus where you do press are like different locations. Yeah. Blackberry was cause Blackberry had a really, actually Blackberry had, um, still I have an, I have an Android now, and I still think my BlackBerry, last BlackBerry I had with a virtual keyboard was a better virtual keyboard than this Android I have right now. Because it was better at that, figuring out where you meant to click, where you thought you were typing.
另外，黑莓还有一个……我不知道，因为有了物理键盘，你就无法使用他们在虚拟键盘上玩的那种各种把戏。就像在虚拟键盘上，他们可以搞这一套，你知道，“哦，你按的是这里，但你其实是想按这里。”哦，是的。你知道的，因为，因为你以为你的手指按的地方和实际按的地方是不同的位置。是的，黑莓之所以……因为黑莓曾经有一个……实际上黑莓有一个……我现在还在用安卓，我依然认为我拥有的最后一款带有虚拟键盘的黑莓手机，其虚拟键盘比我现在的这款安卓手机还要好。因为它在搞清楚你想点哪里、你以为自己在哪里打字这方面做得更好。
And it had better prediction. And also BlackBerry was the only phone that had prediction that didn't send your text home to do the prediction. It was all on phone because BlackBerry is like totally paranoid about security. Well, that's been BlackBerry's market. That's why BlackBerry still makes phones. Like if you work for certain government agencies you probably have blackberry well and you know not only did you have a blackberry you had a blackberry made in canada like we would sell blackberries to everyone else that might be made in wherever but the ones you sold to the government were built in canada like everything about it was built again Canada. Now I still wonder.
而且它的预测功能更好。而且黑莓是唯一一款其预测功能不会把你的文本发送回云端去做预测的手机。所有功能都在手机本地运行，因为黑莓对安全性有着彻底的偏执。好吧，那是黑莓的市场。这就是为什么黑莓至今仍在制造手机。如果你在某些政府机构工作，你可能就有黑莓。而且你知道，你不仅有一部黑莓，你还有一部在加拿大制造的黑莓。我们会把黑莓卖给其他人，它们可能在任何地方制造，但卖给政府的那批是在加拿大制造的。关于它的一切都是在加拿大制造的。现在我仍然很好奇。
Were the chips fabbed in Canada? Yeah, that's the weird part. The chips was still Qualcomm. So like, you know, wherever. But everything that could be was in Canada. So, and people like the US were very happy that we were friendly partners. Anyhow, yep.
那些芯片是在加拿大晶圆厂制造的吗？对，那是奇怪的部分。芯片仍然是高通的。所以，你知道的，无论在哪里。但所有可能在加拿大的东西都在加拿大。所以，像美国这样的人非常高兴我们是友好的合作伙伴。不管怎样，是的。
Do you think there's a parallel universe where blackberry um managed to compete and still is you know is there up with android or was it inevitable that if they stuck with the keyboard and uh well you know what they they should have gone to android sooner for sure um blackberry could have been the the like one of the top android phones um blackberry was going to go to android early days of android before before it was like just kind of decided like before samsung took over you know and things like that um but the um google versus Google versus Oracle, Java lawsuit was going on, right? Like Google was getting sued by Java, right? And so BlackBerry was like,
你觉得有没有这样一个平行宇宙，黑莓成功完成了竞争，到现在还和安卓平起平坐？还是说，如果他们坚持使用键盘……其实他们早该换到安卓了，黑莓本可以成为顶级的安卓手机之一。在安卓的早期，也就是三星崛起之前，黑莓其实打算转向安卓的。但当时谷歌和甲骨文关于Java的官司正在进行，对吧？谷歌被甲骨文起诉了，所以黑莓当时觉得，
let's not get involved with that. We were on good relationship with Oracle and Sun and all the business side. We don't want to mess up with that. We can't go to Android right now because there's big question marks whether Android will even survive the lawsuit. So instead, they went to QNX and made their own OS, which was cool.
我们还是别卷进去了。我们和甲骨文、Sun以及整个商业生态的关系都很好，不想趟这趟浑水。我们现在不能用安卓，因为这场诉讼会不会让安卓倒闭都还是个大问号。于是，他们转向了QNX并开发了自己的操作系统，这其实挺酷的。
Like BlackBerry 10 was... And the funny part is, this is actually how I started on the C++ committee. BlackBerry 10 was the only phone OS where the, you know, premier language for writing applications was C++, right? If you're on iPhone, it used to be Objective-C and now it's Swift. If you're on Android, it was Java. Now Java Kotlin. Windows had a phone, but they wanted you to use C Sharp.
比如黑莓10系统……有趣的是，我也就是这样开始加入C++委员会的。黑莓10是唯一一个编写应用程序的首选语言是C++的手机操作系统，对吧？如果你用iPhone，过去是Objective-C，现在是Swift。如果你用安卓，以前是Java，现在是Java和Kotlin。Windows也有过手机，但他们希望你用C#。
And they all kind of like, maybe you could use C++ if you tried really hard. But if you wanted to write an app for BlackBerry, you could use some other languages. But the number one choice of language, the one we pushed, was C++. It was the C++ phone, right? And everything was like native C++. And that's one of the reasons I joined the committee, because I actually said, I mean, I was already involved. I was already going to Boost conferences and C++ Now, and people like Beeman Dawes wanted me.
它们其实都……如果你费尽心思的话，也许能用C++。但如果你想为黑莓写应用，你可以用其他语言，不过首选语言、也是我们大力推广的语言是C++。这就是那部C++手机，对吧？一切都是原生的C++。这也是我加入委员会的原因之一，因为我当时就说——其实我当时已经参与进去了，我当时已经去参加Boost会议和C++ Now了，像比曼·道斯（Beeman Dawes）这样的人希望我加入。
I met him at Boost Boost and he's like, hey, come on to the committee. He's one of the reasons, he's an awesome guy. He's one of the reasons I got on to the committee. But I also, I was at BlackBerry and I said, hey, you're the only phone that is relying on C++ and you know who's in the committee? Microsoft, Apple, and Google, right? They are
我在Boost会议上遇到了他，他说，嘿，来加入委员会吧。他是原因之一，他是个超级棒的人，是我加入委员会的原因之一。但同时，我在黑莓工作，我说，嘿，你们是唯一依赖C++的手机，而你们知道委员会里都有谁吗？微软、苹果和谷歌，对吧？他们
in control of the language you chose for your phone. Your three top competitors are in charge of the language you're using. So you should have somebody on the committee to speak for BlackBerry. And it's actually funny because I wrote this long email saying like all these that and a bunch of other reasons why blackberry should have someone on the committee and then at the very end it's like by the way that person should be me like if it wasn't clear and this email went to my manager and up and went all the way up to the ceo and i ended up getting an email back that the ceo's response was just like well who should it be and it's like well did you read the whole thing or not right and and my manager sent back to the CEO's response was just like, well, who should it be? And it's like, well, did you read the whole thing or not? Right. And, and my manager sent back to the CEO, it should be Tony, like no question. And so I got, I was on the committee. And then of course,
在掌控着你们手机所选择的语言。你们最大的三个竞争对手正在掌控你们所使用的语言。所以你们应该在委员会里派个代表来为黑莓发声。说来好笑，我当时写了一封很长的邮件，列举了所有这些原因以及其他一堆黑莓应该派人加入委员会的理由，然后在最后写道：顺便说一句，那个人应该是我（如果还没说清楚的话）。这封邮件发给了我的经理，然后一层层往上送，一直到了CEO那里。最后我收到了一封回信，CEO的反应居然是：“那到底该选谁呢？”这简直就像是——你到底有没有把整封信看完啊？对吧？然后我的经理回复CEO说，那个人非托尼（Tony）莫属，毫无疑问。于是我就加入了委员会。然后当然，
it was the CEO of, I want to say Mike Lombardi, but that Lazarus or Lazarus, Mike L it's right. Anyhow, because it's Mike L internally he was called Mike L here's another story I just told the other day at work tune in next week to hear Tony's story this is part one of a four part interview series with Tony Van Eerd thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那位CEO是……我想说是迈克·伦巴迪（Mike Lombardi），但其实是拉撒路（Lazarus）或者拉撒路……迈克·L（Mike L），对吧。不管怎样，因为他在内部被称为迈克·L。我前几天在工作时刚讲了另一个故事。请关注下周的节目，收听托尼的故事。这是与托尼·范·埃尔德（Tony Van Eerd）进行的四部分系列访谈的第一部分。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。